[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just molested that sign yesterday I
think they're I think they're running
out of steam there here are some
BuzzFeed lists I saw recently they
weren't very impressive here's 117
interviews where Ben Carson was sleep
talking yeah seriously seven people
seven people who never agreed to have
their Pelle snooze to highlight the
obesity epidemic or gal didn't give the
permission nine dentists who insist on
wearing capes 13 men buns you don't want
to smell you want no part of that man
bun trust me 16 Cheesecake Factory meals
under 10,000 calories good to keep in
mind if you're feeling healthy 11 books
that are only used to level tables
[Applause]
did not write a book called filler up
all these salty dr. Phil impression uh
18 nurses you would never suspect have
murdered their patients check this one
out
five mcribs that aren't coming back Nick
rib wants out twelve jars of urine still
enjoying this Shia LeBoeuf movie
marathon yeah
America's seventeen best nauseated
grandmas wouldn't if that one didn't
make anybody happy fifteen pics of guys
in Guy Fawkes masks going number two six
table saw accidents that weirdly
resulted in more fingers and finally
seven people already disguised his movie
theater seats to sneak into the forest
awakened
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]